speaking of taxes I think you had this
exact debate with Ben Shapiro I remember
you're saying I don't think taxes should
be zero but I also don't think it should
be 100 he was debating on like yeah in
the Reagan days it was 91 that's
something
what's the number so Patrick uh I used
to be a republican uh and so my dad left
it started so his dirt poor Southeastern
turkey uh Olive farmer
um the reason part of the reason I'm
Progressive today is because in Turkey
back in the 1960s they had free college
education to anyone who could score the
top okay so my dad and my uncle worked
their ass off to score at the top of the
of those College interest exams and
without any money they got into the he
got in the best engineering school in
Turkey then he set up his own company I
mean he is the American dream and I
interviewed him and conservatives loved
him right and they're like how did a
jackass like you come out of that guy
right and so and I and it will go even
further my dad was basically chasing a
turkey by communist so he had set up a
business and they were threatening his
life because he was a capitalist Pig
okay now still we're Progressive because
we have none of this if the government
did not provide a free college education
to my dad right now I'd be an olive
farmer in Southeastern turkey a lot of
the right wing is going ah yeah
right so
um now having said that though uh why
did I leave the Republican party because
every part of it turned out to be
marketing so like you talk about the
defense
budget right do we need a strong
military of course we need a strong
military uh and so you can't have no
military that's nuts right but um but do
we need this level of monstrous spending
with no accountability where they waste
billion after billion because it's not
wasted it's going in the pocket of
Defense Contractor Executives so the
correct answer is balanced so that
brings us to taxes so when they had it
at 91 right then we were Republicans and
and Reagan came in it was still at 70
our families still Republicans right
nobody paid 91 by the way at that time
just so you know yeah but nobody ever
paid 91 there was so many loopholes the
average guy was paying 40 to 50 percent
who was making money because they so
even though I get what you're saying to
40 Years of taxes there's nobody that
was paying 91 of the time yeah and
people have to understand that that's
above a certain number so the numbers
the famous story with Reagan was that he
would make 100 grand for each movie and
then after 200 Grand is the time this is
in the 40s whatever it was anything over
200 Grand it's at 91 he's like I'm not
doing a third freaking movie because I
make nine percent of the movie so he
would just do two movies a year and that
was basically impetus for his tax plan
yeah so so there is a point where taxes
are too high right but right now we've
lowered taxes 128 times I'm making that
number up it's hyper but it but probably
if you looked at the real number it
might be right around that or more we're
constantly lowering taxes on rich and
most importantly corporations right so
and then they remember when they're in
the Trump tax cut they were going to do
two trillion dollars mainly for
corporations what happened Mr populist
uh and then they were supposed to take
away the loopholes what they do instead
they did two trillion dollars in Texas
they didn't take away a single loophole
they were lying all the time Republicans
relying Democrats were lying none of
them took away a single goddamn loophole
so it was a two trillion dollar giveaway
uh to the richest people in the country
and to corporations so taxes should be
around it should be layered right
Progressive like Reagan uh so late well
Progressive taxes is American like we've
had progressive taxation in America
where would you put the Top Line
you know above a billion dollars uh it
would it would be a it'd be a high
number I mean fifty percent at least
above a billion dollars in earnings or
earnings in earnings yeah you're not
talking capital gains capital gains I
put it whatever is the normal tax I
think I think it's outrageous capital
gains is low okay yeah so okay so
interesting so there's a few things that
you know you just said that uh uh uh uh
I actually you know like when you say
corporations you know I can't believe
what you know we had the corporation
taxes because our corporation tax were
the lowest it was the highest at 35
points nobody paid that to your point
you're right nobody paid it but it was
high because they just kind of let the
money flow and they took it out by debt
or dividends or in different ways that
it can avoid paying that 35 and then I
think Trump brought it down to 21 21 and
then it's back up to 25 more they're
gonna move it up
so that's exactly how the good got pad
cop of Republicans Democrats Republicans
bring it down from 35 20 one Biden comes
and goes I'm going to bring it back to
28. wait it wasn't at 28 it was a 35.
mainstream media doesn't say a word
about it right then Manchester says I
don't want 28 I want 25 and then Biden
says I am the Bold leader who's going to
get it to you at 25. wait a minute you
guys just took 10 points off the
corporate tax rate and Biden did that
under the Obama Administration by the
way Bush passed massive tax cuts for the
rich but they couldn't make him
permanent because it was so unpopular
that Obama gets into office has Biden
negotiate with Mitch McConnell he makes
94 of the tax cuts for the rich
permanent
the Democrats did that not the
Republicans it was Biden himself it was
such a terrible deal that other
conservative Democrats were livid
they're like how could you give
McConnell 94 on what he wanted by that's
why I say Biden is conservative Biden
would give Republicans anything they
want 24 7. they have too many stuff on
Biden if you ask me but here's the other
part you know how every time they're
like let's send money to you know to
people to help them out and bail them
out every time they print the money and
send money to them what are your
thoughts on sending money to people hey
here's a thousand dollars a week
stimulus checks what's what are your
thoughts on so like an Andrew Yang model
even a Ubi I would assume you would
support someone no okay so
um so that it all depends on context it
all depends on the facts so when we were
in the middle of covid did people need
to relieve checks yes so I supported
that completely
um
UBI has some issues including they take
away a lot of Social Services to be able
to do Ubi and I don't love that concept
and and so I you know and and
progressives are split about uba there's
a lot of different thoughts on it and
I'm sure there's good progressives who
love it and would disagree with me but I
think just giving money is not the most
productive way of the government
handling it if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]